what is your guys favorite scary movie
like so you like well Beetlejuice isn't
a full but you know yeah I like it's
it's creepy I would consider it a scary
movie um I also like Coraline yeah it's
super creepy somehow I can never get
through Coraline somehow something
happens and I can't watch the rest of it
but yeah well like it's what did what in
that movie stops you what are you what
scares you in that but you just get
distracted well my mom like something
happens like I have to go clean my room
one day you will
I like Oh a movie you know a movie a
movie that I can never if I see it on TV
I can't turn it off I have to watch the
entire thing which I consider horror
movies a Zodiac it's a great it's so
great three hours I have to watch it how
many times have you seen so yeah I what
if I see it well you know usually I'll
catch it but I think that's it's like
technically a horror movie it's like
based on real life but I love I love
recently left hereditary London Simard
all that stuff yeah what scares you both
the most you have a leg feel you go okay
yeah I don't nowadays um I'm trying to
think I don't really have like like I'm
not oh I'm afraid of like mice actually
like rat if I see a rat like scurrying
or if I there's like a rat or something
like in my house or whatever I would
freak out is it just critters in general
yeah like possums disgust eh hey possum
if I see a possible on the side of the
road I'm like dude no all the rodents I
hate this even this right now
[Music]
[Laughter]
well like a lot of like your characters
go through a lot of like emotional
turmoil this one how do you how do you
sort of prepare yourself for those sort
of a big emotional scenes
oh yeah that's well they we will just
take time to sulk yeah I just kind of
sulk no I uh
I don't know we try to keep it as like
as the most like positive set we can
like but when we're preparing for like
creepy weird scenes I don't know we we
like doing the scene and then kind of
like breaking out of it in between takes
so it's not like too much of a bummer
and films oh yeah oh yeah of course when
she cries in the car I didn't know if
speak and she hasn't seen it yet she was
like we kept it positive when we were
starting driving I started doing
hyperventilating you know all that stuff
all that emotional stuff but because it
was really good after like she came in
and just like curled up in a ball of her
do they tell you when they're gonna
start shooting strangers things for yeah
in a few months a few months yeah I
what's called they have literally I have
some I know one person through the
entire cast and crew that has got some
scrip mm-hmm I do you cast them for info
sometimes yeah well yeah I would text
the deaf or something they're like just
wait until the month before you guys are
sadist that's fun it should be a really
good season yeah I I just like stranger
things in general yeah I do not like
that he kisses Milly she doesn't like
she gets kicked out by the piston rings
at the TV
she gets really freaked out by all this
deal with it it's the job